yeah welcome to this video new five
minute let's game against road runners
from Australia done come the Kings
Indian let's see i recently want a nice
game with the exchange but yeah don't
get it to this time okay i know its
specialty tool right yeah this is a very
weird line I know this g4 anticipates a
black plain e5 and instead you can play
c5 and we get this position now which is
very similar to amarok see bind the
differences are the weird thing is that
I have a porn on g4 but other than that
it's just normal the weird thing as in
addition that black has got some really
badly placed pieces Queen only eight in
particular no I'm sorry hmm yeah how to
how to continue
okay let's play only to first connect
rooks but not so sure how to set up the
pieces here sometimes I see an F 45s as
a possible plan damn he tries to prepare
be five maybe i can i can play on 95 on
on on this okay 95 know maybe now
shouldn't be too bad pressurizing f6 not
sure but maybe i'm really threatening to
take it on f6 and damage the support
structure if he takes and I recapture
with the porn on I am should have an
excellent position with the 7-pole being
a target
yeah I'm not sure what you should do now
maybe b5 after all it's not not easy to
play on 96 maybe can allow that I'm not
sure the problem is whatever I give up
this bishop on 1g5 my dark squares are
weakened this position would be M
without any doubt better for white with
the porn on g3 but it's on g4 it's not
much that I can do against that and this
weakens the the King side and he's loved
me link me to check quickly wow it's got
a good ping time even so to stop the
disconnection
yeah not sure what he's doing he did
he's not not moving at all now there
must be some problem no one is going to
thank God one and a half minutes on this
move okay now it's moving yeah the
question is some here should i take to
take or not to take love's not sure
maybe it is better to to keep pieces on
and increase with rocky one and so and
so on Knight takes f6 them should take
so I'm not sure that I can get done
pressure on on d6 oh good glad I don't
really want to exchange the dark squared
Bishop Knight to g5 I should threaten
that may be but right now it's not a
threat but here it is Oh Bishop f6 and
95 the service may be a friend now
Bishop s6 Bush web 695 22 Knight f6
check King g7 and then maybe just off
recapture on the 212 King f6 looks like
he's got some problems oh wait 95 now as
even 97 okay let's go let's do this yeah
hmm interesting should i when i teach 5
is so ridiculous problem now f4 or not
yeah probably a 485 if he goes oh he
doesn't thought he would play if I
himself but didn't do that okay man yes
then let's use the space here yeah but I
have this before and c5 should be strong
this was always important that I have
this idea this this Bishop d7 as well be
seven and taking yeah i can i can
actually do that
oh wait hey I can can do that maybe his
son going to d5 hmm that's a bit rocky
now maybe I shouldn't have taken fit
this is unnecessarily complicated now I
shouldn't have done that just a simple
technical play would've won rather
easily and now this isn't so clear
oh I versus covered oh no I'm warning
don't believe that it's impossible yeah
what a nonsense game completely
completely dominating this and then
stupidly giving it away yeah why on
earth did I grabbed a six porn I mean
this is just just over this position
just with normal moves ruby three or
something dominating the night after
that he doesn't even have a move coming
well maybe maybe you can play what I did
but it's not done it's not a practical
choice and a blitz game let's check this
but probably and probably I really
shouldn't do that yeah this is the only
move but it's like it's the vision to to
continue this yeah just just something
like this he has no roof absolutely no
you can try this I just play a 3 and
this is so done I mean I can even play
Bishop have one later and pick this up
conveniently the night has no move it is
dead on 84 no yeah just bad play by me
but rugby 7s it's just bad right thanks
for watching